Hi guys. Welcome
to this lecture,
Histology of the Skin, Part 1,
Epidermis, Dermis, and
Hypodermis. My name is
Brian Bagelman. I'm one
of the academic medicine
scholars for the 2026
year. And thank you to Dr.
Kurtzer for letting me
record this lecture.
Here are both of our
emails. If you guys have any
questions regarding this
lecture, please feel
free to email us, we'll
be happy to answer them.
So for session objectives
for this lecture,
there are five of them.
Number one,
identify the general
divisions of the
skin. Number two,
distinguish the
different types of
regional variations
of the skin.
Number three, describe the
development, organization,
and functions of
keratinocytes. Number four,
identify the other
cells of the epidermis,
their spatial arrangement
and functions.
And number five,
contrast the two dermal
layers along with their
associated structures.
So some previous
lectures that you
guys might find helpful
for this lecture.
Two from FOM, Introduction
to Histology Part 2, Tissues,
Fibers, and Cells, and
FOM, Histology of the
Epithelium. From PPOM1 for
this semester, you guys might
find general sensory systems
to be useful so let's
start broad and talk about
skin as an organ it's also
called the integument and
as you guys can see by the
wide variety of functions
listed here it's a complex
organ it has many layers it
has regional specialization
and the functions listed
here play a crucial
role in our daily life it
acts as a barrier against
water, mechanical pressure,
and ultraviolet radiation.
It provides an immunological
function against pathogens.
It has an endocrine
function in helping make
vitamin D. It has an exocrine
function where it plays a
role in the secretion of
sweat and sebum. It has a
homeostasis function where it
plays a role in temperature
regulation. And it has
a sensory function. You
know we use our skin to
feel touch hot cold and pain
so here are the general
divisions of the skin we have
the epidermis we have the
dermis and we have the
hypodermis so the epidermis
is keratinized stratified
squamous epithelium i know
that's a mouthful it is
derived from the ectoderm
it's avascular meaning that
there are no blood vessels
going to this portion and
it's attached to the basement
membrane of the dermis
moving on to the dermis
it's dense connective tissue
it's derived from the mesoderm
and it's highly vascular
the hypodermis sits below
the dermis and it is
subcutaneous fascia composed
of septa septa meaning
fibrous sheets and adipose
adipose means fat and just
like the dermis it's also
derived from the mesoderm
and it's also very vascular
so before we move on
i'd like to address this
picture right here which
shows the different layers
of the skin so the e is the
epidermis k you can see
a bundle of keratin right
here pd and rd are both
from the dermis and why it's
called pd and rd we'll get
to later on in lecture.
And SC is the hypodermis.
And also EG is an ekran gland.
So something else I'd
like to touch on is the
epidermal appendages.
They're found throughout the
layers of the skin and
they include hair, sweat
glands, sebaceous glands,
nails, and mammary glands.
So it's important to note
the histological definition
on thick versus thin skin.
So we have thick skin is
represented by this picture
here and thin skin is
here. So thick skin, as
you guys can tell, the
epidermis is very thick. It
covers the skin of the palms
and soles. The reason our
palms and soles have thick
skin, histologically speaking,
is because these areas
have increased mechanical
interaction with the world.
So we evolved a thicker
skin in these areas to act
as a mechanical barrier.
Thin skin, on the other
hand, the epidermis is very
thin and it's everywhere
else. So that means that
even though our eyelids and
back feel like the skin is
different in terms of
thickness, right? The skin on
your back is much thicker than
your eyelid. Histologically
speaking, it's all
thin skin. And the only
places that have thick skin,
again, are the palms of
your hands and soles of our
feet so another distinction
in skin is glabrous versus
non-glabrous glabrous
is hairless skin so that
would be a human palm and
non-glabrous means hairy
skin so if you take a look
at the cat pads right
here that would be non
-glabrous because there's a
lot of hair here so putting
it together if we go back
to the previous slide
where we distinguished
between thick and thin skin
thick skin is glabrous and
thin skin is non-glabrous
because thin skin has
hair and thick skin does
not if you take a look at
your hands our hands and
soles don't have hair
but we have hair on every
other portion of our skin.
So we can't talk histology
of the skin without talking
about keratinocytes.
They are the
predominant cell of
the epidermis, more
than 85% of it.
They originate in
the deepest layer
of the epidermis
and grow outward,
kind of like this
tree right here where
everything originates in
the center and grows out.
The difference between
us and trees is that in
trees they stay our skin
gets slapped off eventually
keratinocytes make keratin
which is a structural
protein of epithelial
cells in all vertebrates
and keratinocytes form
the epidermal water
barrier so this is what
i was talking about
with skin is continuously
developed and shed
slash de-squamated, same
thing, versus trees.
So now let's talk about the
layers of the epidermis.
I'll be starting from the
outermost layer and going
deep. So this layer is
distratum corneum. It is the
outermost layer. It's made
up of keratin-filled dead
keratinocytes, and these
dead keratinocytes are called
squains. They don't have
nuclei, and this layer varies
most in thickness. Again,
thick versus thin skin.
The layer after that is
the stratum granulosum.
It is the diamond-shaped
keratinocytes, and
these keratinocytes contain
keratohylin granules.
Up next, we have the
stratum spinosum.
so here the keratinocytes
are irregular polyhedral
keratinocytes with desmosomes
that link neighboring
cells the reason it's called
spinosome is because they
kind of look like spines
and last but not least we
have the stratum Basilar
which is the deepest layer and
it's separated from the
dermis by the basement
membrane and attached by
hemidesmosomes. So again, desmosomes
for the entirety of the
stratum spinosum and
hemidesmosomes are for the
stratum Basilar connected to
the basement membrane to
the dermis. Here in the
stratum Basilar, the cells
are cuboidal to columnar and
they are the most mitotically
active keratinocytes.
So an important thing
to know is that the
stratum Basilar is a
single layer. It's also
called the germinal layer.
It's just one layer.
And in the stratum spinosum,
the keratinocytes move
up at different rates. They
end up jostling each other
and that's what gives them
the irregular appearance.
also you guys might
notice that here we have
the stratum lucidum we're
not going to go too much
into detail but it's
the thin layer of cells
between the stratum corneum
and stratum granulosum
it's only evident in
thick skin and it's
considered a subdivision
of the stratum corneum
so here we can see a
bit more in depth so
again here we have
the stratum corneum
the stratum granulosum,
the stratum spinosum,
and a singular
stratum Basilar layer.
And over here we have the
desmosomes in the
stratum spinosum.
And this image is
zoomed in, by the way.
So let's talk about the
development and migration of
keratinocytes. And before I
fully get started, I'd like
to point out that the green
text correlates to the
green in the picture, and
the purple text correlates to
the purple in the picture.
So just to give you guys a
frame of reference. So starting
with the stratum Basilar,
the basal keratinocyte
begins synthesis of keratin,
which is organized into
groups called tonofilaments,
which are then themselves
grouped into bundles called
tonofibrils. and it's these
tonal fibrils that are
inserted into desmosomes. So
then the keratinocytes are
pushed into the stratum
spinosum. They begin doing two
things. First, they begin
producing keratohylin granules
to aggregate keratin filaments,
and they begin conversion
into cornified cells.
These keratohylin granules
contain filagrin and
trichohylin, which help aggregate
keratin and at this stage the
keratinocytes also produce
lamellar bodies. So then
these cells are pushed into
the stratum granulosum
and become flattened. They
accumulate keratohylin granules
mixed between tonofibrils.
So then these cells enter
the stratum corneum. Here
they lose their organelles
including the nuclei and
lamellar bodies which means
that there is no more metabolic
activity, there's no more
mitotic activity, and the
carotohyline granules turn
the tone of fibrils into a
homogenous keratin matrix,
as you guys can see right
over here, and this becomes
the keratinized cell. This
is another image showing
the process of disquamation,
you know, how the skin
actually gets shed so that we
don't accumulate it. So as
the cells move up, the pH
actually decreases. Here
you guys see that the pH is
6.8 to 7.5 and it goes up
and the pH decreases to
roughly 4.5 to 5.3. So
cornified cells are desquamated
via the breakdown of
desmosomes. so as you guys can
see over in this image
right here so there's a
proteinase activity of a resonant
enzyme of the interstitial
fluid called klk calycrein
related serine peptidase
and this is triggered by
the lowered ph near the
surface so the lower ph
activates klk to break down
the desmosomes. And there's
one more protein, the
lymphoepithelial causal
type inhibitor inhibits KLK.
So here's this protein.
And if you guys focus your
attention to this circle
right here, you guys can
see that the KLK is bound
to its inhibitor, the LEKTI
protein. And as the pH
decreases this purple
protein, the inhibitor detaches
from KLK and that allows
KLK to do its job to
break down the desmosomes.
So here's
the daughter cell in the
stratum Basilar all the
way to when it reaches
the stratum granulosum. It
takes roughly 30 days. To go
from the stratum granulosum
into the stratum
corneum, which is a fully
characterized skin, it only
takes two to six hours.
And what's interesting is
that from the time it reaches
the stratum corneum to
its discolmation takes 15
days. So we have 30 days to
go from stratum Basilar past
the spinosum into the stratum
corneum, 30 days, only
two to six hours to go from
granulosum to corneum, and
then 15 days to get desquamated.
So here's an example
of an accelerated maturation
of keratinocytes where
before we talked about 30
days for a keratinocyte to
mature, they only mature in
8 to 10 days and it's called
psoriasis, also known as
epidermal hyperplasia. And
here are example pictures
here. There is insufficient
development of tonal fibrils
and keratohylin. The granular
layer does not form
normally and what happens is
is that the skin surface
has white flakes over thick
red epidermis. Essentially
the dead cells will be poorly
formed and when they reach
the surface they're not
yet keratinized. So there's
no time in the maturation
process to have good organization
and what you guys can
see in this image right
here is that there's poor
organization, altered
histology, you know, the stratum
granulosum is hard to find
here. And that's psoriasis.
So now let's talk about the
epidermal water barrier. So
we have two components of
it. We have the cell envelope
and we have the lipid
envelope. The cell envelope
is a lattice of insoluble
proteins on the inner surface
of the plasma membrane.
There are cross linking of
small proline-rich proteins
and larger proteins such as
loricrin. And this cell
envelope contributes to the
strong mechanics of the
barrier. For the lipid envelope,
it's lipid, which means it's
hydrophobic, which means
it doesn't like water. So
this lipid envelope layer
is attached to the outer
surface of the plasma membrane.
Here we have lamellar
bodies that are produced in
the stratum spinosum, and
these lamellar bodies have a
mixture of oils. These oils
are exocytosed between the
stratum granulosum and
corneum to release the oils.
So these two components of
the epidermal water barrier
help keep water out. A quick
word on the other cells
of the epidermis. we have
the Langerhans cells, which
functions as the immune cells
of the skin. We obviously
have the keratinocytes,
which are the structural
cells. We talked about them.
And we have melanocytes.
These cells are the cells
that make pigment. We also
have Merkel cells, which
are the sensory cells, but
they'll be covered in the
next lecture. So now let's
talk about melanocytes.
These cells are located
between the cells of the
stratum Basilar. They are
derived from neural crest
cells and they make a pigment,
melanin, in melanosomes,
which is the organelle.
And they provide melanin
granules to keratinocytes
through a process known as
pigment donation. We'll talk
about this on the next
slide and the reason we have
melanin is that melanin
protects against ultraviolet
radiation and this right
here shows the conversion of
tyrosine to L-DOPA to melanin
so this is the biochemical
pathway that makes
melanin how does pigment
donation work so the daughter
cell that moves up the skin
layer phagocytosis a small
portion of the melanocyte
as seen in circles 4 5
and 6 in the image so here
we have the melanocyte and
this is a appendage of the
melanocyte and as you guys
can see a small bleb of the
tendril actually gets
detached from the melanocyte
and the keratinocyte absorbs
it so the daughter cell
engulfs a portion of the
melanocytes tendril the
phagocytosed melanosome continues
to make melanin so while
it's inside the keratinocyte
it still makes melanin
in the keratinocyte
cytoplasm and later on this
melanocytes membrane breaks
down melanin is released into
the keratinocyte cytoplasm
and what the melanin does
it covers the nucleus to
form a cap and that's what
protects the nucleus from
ultraviolet radiation see
the nucleus is protected so
quick word on melanocytes
and skin color the number
of melanocytes is the same
between individuals whether
you have dark skin or
light skin the number of
melanocytes is it's the same.
What is important is that
in darker people, the
melanocytes are more active
and there is slower pigment
degradation in the stratum
spinosum. So it's not the
number of melanocytes, it's
how the melanin is processed
and broken down. So here
we have two disorders
involving melanocytes. We
have albinism and vitiligo.
Albinism is a genetic disorder.
It is autosomal recessive
it is evident in neonates
so when you're first born
and it commonly involves
the eyes and skin so what
happens in albinism is that
there's a lack of mechanism
to develop melanin which
means that you have the
melanocytes but they just
don't make melanin versus
vitiligo which is an autoimmune
disorder there is a lack
of melanocytes and it only
affects certain portions
of the skin and it is
expressed at any time in life.
People are otherwise healthy.
Only 20% are comorbid
with other autoimmune
diseases, especially
in the thyroid.
And what happens here is
that the immune system
actually attacks melanocytes
and causes melanocyte
death. So in albinism,
again, you have the
melanocytes, they just
don't make the melanin. In
vitiligo, that's where you
have of melanocyte death.
And in this example,
in albinism,
it's OCA, oculocutaneous
albinism. This is
just one example of the
many types of albinism.
Her eyes are involved, which
leads to poorer vision.
And again, there are
other subtypes. So now,
a word on Langerhans cells.
These are immune system
cells. They are antigen
-presenting. They are
mostly located in the
stratum spinosum, and they
have a mesenchymal origin,
which means that they are
derived from bone marrow
stem cells, and they're
a part of the mononuclear
phagocytic system. They
have cytoplasmic processes,
CP, which you guys
can see in this portion
of the image right here,
specifically here, and these
are tendrils that reach
out, retract, and move in
different directions, and what
that allows the Langerhans
cell to do is to sample
the space around them and
what they're doing is they're
looking for antigens and
when they find an antigen,
they grab it and retract it
and move on down to the lymph
system to present it further
to your immune system.
So these cytoplasmic
processes have MHC1 and MHC2
molecules and they're immobile.
They are mobile, which
allows them to move to the
lymphatic system to present
the antigens. And burbic
granules, which is in this photo
right here. You guys can
almost appreciate how it
almost looks like a tennis
racket of sorts. And what
these are are organelles
that are only found in the
Langerhans cell. and the
function of these granules, the
burbic granules, is to
enclose and degrade pathogens.
So I touched on this
briefly, but what
happens when a
Langerhans cell finds an
antigen? Well, it finds
an antigen, step one.
They dissolve the basement
membrane via enzymes,
which allows it to leave
the epidermis, it enters the
lymphatic system, and
presents the antigen to a T
cell. So this is an example
of what Langerhans cells,
what they can do. This is a
delayed type hypersensitivity
reaction, otherwise
known as contact allergic
dermatitis. so the man in
the photo put on some cologne
and a couple of days later
his skin you know became
all red itchy white and
flaky and this resolved
again after a few more
days after not using that
cologne so the cologne was
stimulating the Langerhans
cells to flare up the immune
system let's move on to
the dermal epidermal
junction where the epidermis
meets the dermis what happens
here is that anchoring
filaments do what the name
suggests and they anchor
the hemidesmosomes to the
type 4 collagen right here
and type 7 collagen is
connected to the type 4 collagen
and it loops around and
as it loops around fibers
of type 1 and type 3
collagen run through these
loops. And what that essentially
means is that the type
7 collagen acts as a tether
and connects the type
4 collagen to the type 1
and type 3 collagen fibers.
And so this slide puts
what I said in the previous
slide essentially into
writing where the epidermis
is connected to the dermis
via hemidesmosomes and
the hemidesmosomes reside
over here. The basement
membrane is at the junction
of the epidermis, like all
epithelial tissue, and it
is composed of collagen.
So in this picture,
you guys can see that
cytokeratins, which are
made of tonal filaments,
attach to the hemidesmosomes
inside the keratin site's
plasma membrane. So this
is what the PM stands
for, plasma membrane. And on
the other side, outside of
the cell, anchoring
filaments are what attach the
hemidesmosome to the type
4 collagen. And so the
basement membrane is attached
to collagen fibers of the
papillary dermis via these
type 7 collagen loops that
again tethered to type
4 collagen to type 1 and
type 3 collagen. So here's a
scanning electron microscope
image of the dermal
epidermal junction. So BC is
the basal cell. The ME over
here is the melanocyte.
The BM
right here in this
box is the basement
membrane. The TF stands
for tone of filament
and it's right here.
And HD stands for
hemidesmosome which is
right here. You guys can
you guys can see that.
So we spent a long time
talking about the epidermis.
Let's move right along
and talk about the
dermis. So the dermis is
connective tissue derived
from mesoderm. It's
vascularized and it houses the
epidermal appendages and
many sensory neurons.
It has two divisions due
to and correspond to the
types of connective tissue
found in the layers.
and there's no real
dividing layer between
them so the two layers
the papillary layer and
the reticular layer
so the papillary layer
is this layer right here
it's the outer layer
connected to the basement
which is connected to the
epidermis it's composed
of loose connective tissue
which is also known as
areolar connective tissue
there's a lots of there's
lots of ground substance,
type 1 and type 3
collagen, and generally
speaking, it's
thinner and paler.
The reticular layer,
on the other hand,
is deeper, it's less
cellular, it's composed of
dense elastic and irregular
connective tissue, and
you'll also find bundles
of type 1 collagen fibers
here, but in general,
it's thicker, darker,
coarser, and larger. So the
reason the papillary layer
is loose is that it allows
the skin to be mobile
and flexible and this is
needed to prevent tears
here are just some images
of the dermis the PL here
is the papillary layer and
the RL is the reticular layer
and you guys can appreciate
how different they are
the papillary dermis look
how again look how loose it
is has these papillary
protrusions right here called
dermal papillae and the
folded in pattern leads to
stronger connections between
the epidermis and the dermis
and where the dermis has
dermal papillae the downward
portion of the epidermis
is called the epidermal peg
also known as the reet
ridge which you guys can
appreciate more in this picture
right here so again there's
a tight physical linkage
of the epidermis and dermis
so they kind of lock
together like for example the
teeth on gears and it creates
a very tight connection
so now let's talk about
tattoos so what happens in
tattoos is that ink is
injected directly into the
papillary dermis layer. It's
phagocytosed by a macrophage,
and the ink is kept inside
the macrophage until
that macrophage dies. And
then what happens is that
when the cell dies, the
ink gets released, and then
another macrophage comes
and phagocytoses this ink.
And the more cycles that
happens is that it leads to
a more blurrier tattoo over
time, simply because the
ink is redistributed across
successive generations
of cell. And if the ink
particles are pulverized, for
example, by laser removal,
then that's how you clear
tattoos. So now let's talk
about the vascularization
of the dermis. We have
two plexi, we have the
subpapillary plexus, and we
have the cutaneous plexus.
So the subpapillary plexus
is the most peripheral, it
has loops that enter each
dermal papilla to supply
the above dermis, and you
guys can see this over here.
The cutaneous plexus is
just above the hypodermis.
It's in the lowest layer
of the reticular dermis,
and it supplies the various
epidermal appendages.
Here's a real image, so before
it was just an illustration.
Here's what it actually
looks like under
histology. And note the
circular structures, for example
for example
over here. These are vessels
that surround a gland
or hair follicle. And
also note how dense the
subpapillary plexus is.
And you can also appreciate
that the cutaneous plexus
vessels are larger.
So the dermis also includes
lymphatics and the way this
image is color-coded is
that red is for artery, blue
is for veins, and the white
is the lymphatic system.
So the lymphatic system
runs parallel with the
vasculature and remember the
Langerhound cells that we
talked about earlier? Well
they come here from the
epidermis into this lymphatic
system so now let's talk
about Langer lines of the
reticular dermis here the
collagen and elastic
fibers are consistent in
orientation and form regular
lines of tension as you guys
can see by this image and
what this does is that
it provides integrity to the
skin and this is relevant
for surgeries where if
skin incisions are made
along these lines there is
less scarring so if you cut
with the line less scarring
but if you cut across
the line you get more
scarring all right let's talk
about the hypodermis this is
also called the subcutaneous
fascia it contains
adipose lobules along with
some skin appendages such
as hair follicles, sensory
neurons, and blood vessels.
It's highly vascular.
And this portion, this
layer of the skin,
is important for energy
storage, and it's an
important site for
delivering injections.
So now let's do some
practice questions.
So of these layers
that I provided,
take some time now to
organize them into the
most superficial to
the least superficial.
so here's the answer so
the most superficial is
the stratum corneum the
deepest layer is the
stratum Basilar and the
stratum granulosum is the
second most superficial
and the stratum spinosum
is the second most
deepest so again stratum
Basilar is deepest and
the keratinocytes move up
so practice question
number two this might be a
little challenging a
histologist is researching the
molecule that is responsible
for the desquamation
of skin cells what molecule
is this and what is it
triggered by so congratulations
if you've answered
number one this is calicrian
related sarin peptidase
KLK and it is triggered
by lowered pH of near
the surface, which you
guys can see in this slide.
So in summary, the skin is
the multifunction organ.
The epidermis is composed
of continuously renewing
keratinocytes expressed
as different layers.
The epidermis includes
immune cells and
melanocytes, also serves
as a water barrier.
The dermis is connective
tissue, vascularized,
and houses epidermal
appendages.
And the hypodermis is
composed of adipose.
Thank you guys so much
for watching this lecture.
Here's the link to the
lecture feedback form.
Here's another
picture of Dr. Kurtzer
and I, and yeah,
thanks for watching.